put your weight on this one
boom right there it's fine I have this
one boom this hand there's her spine
I have stain gun hand saying gun
shoulder push your spine opposite gun
shoulder won't push your spine okay this
first movement is on his weapon right
okay so he goes this way and if I stay
back here I'm not gonna get much you see
they're not clean so I have to move my
body in boom body in I we were walking
at this range and he draws on me
so boom I'm over here right I take my
shot I did it him
okay maybe even the muzzle blast that's
gonna happen up to right so the thing is
though I don't want him falling on me I
don't know what else the [\h__\h] going on
so let's put him in hang that range so
that's what I do the first one you're
addressing so he goes whoa you're a
Breton alright you know you're not
deviating he draws boom right try to aim
up to aim
but I like smooth okay we go
you